now some people have said that my
Approach or view on friendships is
transactional Extreme
whatever
and I'll say sure
you're right and
I don't see friendship as a binary term
meaning it's not that we are friends or
not friends it's how good of friends are
we to Define friendship the opposite of
friend would be an enemy or a rival
someone who doesn't root for me they
actively try and destroy my efforts they
try and get me to be emotional rather
than make logical decisions and they try
and distract me from my ultimate goal
and for many of you some of your friends
fit that description now I understand
that people are human and people make
mistakes but if you want the one strike
not three strike one-way ticket out of
my friendship you only have to do one
thing you have to not root for me
meaning you actively resent either
explicitly or implicitly when I win if
you resent me winning why are you here
like the reason they're still there is
because there's a chance that your
success will benefit them but while
you're succeeding they'll still try and
destroy it in case they can bring you
down it's [__] up but it's true so the
reverse of that would be somebody who
roots for you in front of you and most
specifically behind your back real talk
that's one of the hardest things out
there especially amongst guys where it's
very Alpha competitive as soon as your
status starts to raise within the group
You by comparison make everyone else
worse so it's in their best interest to
make you less of a threat to them by
diminishing your status the things like
talking behind your back trying to
distract you make you emotional make you
feel guilty about the things that you're
doing take you away try and label you
with old labels that are your old
identity not aligned with the things
that you want to do later and the thing
is is like I don't think these are bad
people to be clear I don't even think
there's good or bad people anyways the
question is just are they going to help
me towards my long-term goal are they
not if it's more likely they've earned a
spot they're paying their rent for my
time and attention if they're not more
likely to help me hit my goal then for
me the question is is the relationship
more important than my goal and that's a
decision for you I made my goal my most
important thing because I believe that
if I achieve that goal I would feel
better about myself my identity
associated with it and I think that
there would be a new level of friends
who would unlock as I got to that new
level and for me me up to this point
that has been true I'm not trying to
achieve a common life goal and so it
would make sense that my views would be
more extreme than other people's I also
think that some of these views become
compounded when you have increasing
demands for your time if that's not real
for you right now if you don't have
people vying for every minute of your
day right now then what I'm saying might
not be relevant for you but for the
people who do have people buying for
every minute of their day it might make
more sense there's a reason LeBron says
No New Friends
hey LeBron hey LeBron how are you LeBron
he's decided like he doesn't need a new
printer he doesn't trust anyone new and
that's fine that works for him he has a
rare life it would make sense that he
has rare rules you can't really give a
[__] about what people say no more
because everybody gonna [__] critique
everything that you do no matter what
you do they say we're creep into your
mind the biggest issue that I've had
with friendships in general is that
people project what they believe
friendships should look like in their
minds onto our relationship for me I am
transactional this is gonna probably
piss a lot of people off the pros of
this relationship should outweigh the
cons and if people are like I can't
believe you'd say that we probably
wouldn't be friends and that's okay
you'll probably be friends with people
who don't have that definition but for
me that means that like my life is
better off with you in it
you helped me achieve my goal you root
for me along the way if you think about
everything you do as an investor you
invest time and energy into a
relationship with the hopes of getting
some sort of positive return you spend
that time no matter what and the people
who build their best relationships the
best networks are the ones who invest in
relationships that yield the highest
returns in terms of exchange I believe
in abundant exchange which is if both of
us feel like we're getting the better
end of the deal then this relationship
will continue ad infant item it's going
to keep going you would have no reason
to end it where you get into trouble is
the types of relationships that you're
wondering should I keep these you
probably already know you shouldn't and
I love this little framework for
decision making when you're faced
between a hard thing and the easy thing
and you're not sure what to do you
should do the hard thing because if the
easy thing were the right thing to do
you would have already done it one of
the hardest things about pursuing your
dreams and pursuing your goals is that a
lot of the people that are in your life
right now will not support the future
version of you that you need to become
in order to accomplish those goals
people don't actually want the best for
you they want the version of you that
best serves them now the closer they are
to you in terms of long-term alignment
the more likely those two versions of
you will intersect which is often why
often not always why family and your
spouse should hopefully be the most
aligned with you because long term their
best interest is often aligned with your
best interest I think the spouse is like
the nth degree of what the most extreme
French should look like that is the best
friend you have for life which means
they should root for you harder than
anyone else they should never resent
your success the biggest strongest Ally
you have and then the friends you have
are just non-sexualized versions of that
core Ally you have there's a lot of
statements that friends will make to try
and keep you where you're at they'll say
you've changed and they'll phrase it in
a way that makes it feel like you're
doing something wrong by changing all
you have to do is look back at them and
say you're right and you haven't that
carries almost an equal weight back to
them because some people want to stay
the same comma and that's okay that's
been my recurring theme with friendships
is just accepting them for what they are
and saying that's okay things have
changed good that's what growth is you
can't grow and stay the same and if we
want to grow as entrepreneurs then we
have to expect change and I think Tupac
embodies this transition in between
friends really well and he said just
because you lost me as a friend doesn't
mean you gained me as an enemy I'm
bigger than that I still want to see you
eat just not at my table I don't wish
you ill I want you to succeed and I want
you to do all the things you want to do
in your life it's just that your vision
for your life doesn't merge with my
vision for my life it's the same thing
as having an ex-girlfriend or an
ex-boyfriend you had a season together
it doesn't mean you don't honor the
season and all of a sudden start
destroying the memory appreciate the
fact that you had a season understand
that season's by their very nature end
we both contribute to another and then
we found out that we wanted different
things which is great that's the whole
point of learning the thing is a lot of
people have these precepts of what a
friend should be we're going to be
friends for life how many 85 year olds
you know who are friends with the same
people their whole lives not many and if
they are they've got like one
it's not common but it is okay in my
opinion to have seasons of Friends we're
friends for the season and then we had
train tracks that aligned and then we
found out we had train tracks that
diverted comma and that's okay have you
ever had somebody who's like I was just
trying to help and that person just like
made your life 10 times harder that is
not help that is destruction but true
help comes from someone who comes into
your life and all of a sudden everything
gets easier that is Health that is a
friend that is somebody who's an ally
let me give you a little frame shift
around Burning Bridges because people
love using their friends like you don't
want to burn Bridges remember where you
came from you can consider it burning a
bridge but you could also consider it
pruning a tree in order for the tree to
grow you only have certain amount of
sunlight water and minerals in the soil
the healthiest thing for the tree is to
prune it cut the branch off and that may
seem uncomfortable for many of you but
again there's the hard thing and the
easy thing and if you're making the
decision you already know the right
thing is probably the hard one so if you
encounter somebody that's not aligned
with the vision of your life and it used
to be your old life they want to go to
clubs every night they want to drink on
Sundays do the bar crawls and now it's
coming in Conflict they're losing
friends so they want to keep you there
and that's okay like don't hate them for
wanting that it's just that it no longer
aligns anymore I think there's really
two directions for these types of
friendships number one is that if you
decrease the frequency of communication
with someone over time you get fewer and
fewer invites and then it kind of
Fizzles
that's how most friendships or loose
acquaintances end the very hand select
few of times where you have family or
like super close homies whatever you
want to call it I
have one framework for having really
hard conversations that I stole from
Layla keep the other person as a human
being at the Forefront of the
conversation rather than being right if
I remind myself every time I go into
hard conversations that way it's amazing
how much better of a conversation I have
and accepting responsibility for the
fact that like hey I've changed and
that's not on you that's on me if it
means that we're not hanging out as much
anymore again it doesn't mean that you
have me as an enemy comma and that's
okay I think that you can have friends
who aren't necessarily pursuing
greatness as long as they're helping you
pursue yours that's the bridge in my
opinion I like to be inspired by the
people that I'm around I want to admire
something in every friend that I have I
have a very close friend of mine who is
an FBI agent
every time I talk to him he's got like
new stories of things that he's doing
and for me the benefit I get from the
relationship is that it gives me an
escape from the day-to-day business
stuff that I'm dealing with he benefits
in no way from the status from the
followers because he has no way to
financially benefit he's an FBI agent
but what we both mutually appreciate
about one another is that we've both
been committed to being excellent at our
craft I just want people who are as
passionate about their art as I am who
root for me to make the best painting
possible that's what I'm really going
for at the end of the day it's just like
does this person make me better if they
don't then why are you here